[موسيقى]
واهلا بكم معنا الى هذه النشره الاخباريه
من العربيه ونبداها بالعناوين بايدن يؤكد
لقاده شرق اوروبا انه لا يهدف للاطاحه في
بوتين واوكرانيا ترى نفسها جزءا من
النيتوم حكم الامر الواقع
بعد اكتشاف يورانيوم مخصب بنسبه تقترب من
السلاح النووي ونقاش عسكري امريكي
اسرائيلي للوضع الحالي
ونتابع ايضا في نشرتنا هذه
تقرير خاص للعربيه اموال دون رقيب تجد
طريقها الى عائلات داعش في مخيم الهول
وتوفر شريان حياه للتنظيم
العربيه تستحضر مقابلاتها مع قاده العالم
في عيدها العشرين
واهلا بكم من جديد نحييكم من العربيه
زميلي ابراهيم وانا في هذه التغطيه
المستمره لاحداث اليوم العام 20 على
العربيه في تغطيه العيد العشرين كنا على
ذلك الطريق دائما نستقي الخبر من مصدره
قاده وزعماء وصناع قرار كنا هناك منتهى
ولا زلنا على هذا الطريق نسعى دائما
لتقديم افضل خدمه اخباريه لمشاهدي قناه
العربيه على مدى عقدين من الزمان وفي
بدايه هذه الساعه نبدا كالعاده باخر
الاخبار ثم نستذكر لاحقا قليلا من الاعوام
العشرين الاخيره
ذكرت صحيفه بوليتيكو ان الرئيس الامريكي
جو بايدن خلال زيارته لبولندا في فبراير
الماضي ابلغ دول بوخرس التسع نواشنطن لا
تسعى لتغيير القياده في روسيا وذكرت صحيفه
نقلا عن مصادر ان بايدن قال ان الهدف من
الوضع في اوكرانيا ليس تغيير السلطه في
روسيا وتضيف الصحيفه ان بايدن بعد زياره
كييف وفي اجتماع مغلق بوارسو اضطر الى
ارسال تذكير الى دول بخار الست بان الهدف
من الوضع في اوكرانيا لم يكن انهاء نظام
بوتين
اكد رئيس وزراء اوكرانيا ان جيش بلاده
يتبع معايير النيتو في القتال ويستخدموا
اسلحته واكد ان وجود كييف النيتو امر
حقيقي بحكم الامر الواقع
الابواب المفتوحه ليست كافيه بالنسبه لنا
اوكرانيا تسمع هذه الجمل منذ سنوات نريد
ونتوقع قرارات حاسمه من حلفائنا جيشنا
يقاتل باستخدام معدات الناتو وقواتنا
المسلحه تعمل بمعايير النيتو وجودنا في
النيتو امر واقع
اكد سفير اوكرانيا لدى المانيا
كييف تناقش مع حلفائها احتياجاتها في
حربها مع روسيا بطريقه دقيقه للغايه مشيرا
الى ان وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه لم تطلب
بعد نوعا معينا من الطائرات من المانيا
بطريقه دقيقه للغايه وغنيه بالمحتوى حتى
هذه اللحظه لم اتلقى اي طلب من وزاره
دفاعنا لنوع معين من الطائرات المتوفره في
المانيا اعلم ان مثل هذه المناقشات تجري
مع دول اخرى لكن مثل هذه المحادثات لا
تحدث عبر تويتر ولكن خلف الابواب المغلقه
وكان نائب مجلس الامن الروسي ديمتري قال
ان تسليم الناتو الطائرات الى اوكرانيا
وصيانتها في بولندا سيكون دخول مباشرا
للحلف في الحرب ضد روسيا واكد نائب رئيس
مجلس الامن الرو سي انه سيتعين اعتبار كل
من يقرر توريد او صيانه هذه المعدات او
وسائل التدمير الى جانب المرتزقه
والمدربين الاجانب اكد انه سيتم اعتبارهم
اهداف مشروعه على حد وصفه
اكد مؤسس فاجنر ان القوات الروسيه حاصرت
عمليا مدينه باخموت بالكامل لافتا الى
امتلاك القوات الاوكرانيه الطريق خروج
واحد من المدينه وافقه تعبيره ودعا مؤسسه
فاجنر الرئيس
الاوكرانيسكي الى سحب قواته من المدينه
التي تعد الجبهه الاكثر اشتعالا منذ اشهر
وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه اعلنت ان صيغه
السلام التي قدمها الرئيس الاوكراني
لا تهدف في الواقع الى تسويه سلميه للصراع
واضافت الخارجيه في بيان بان زيلينسكي
يواصل الترويج لما يسمى بصيغته للسلام
والتي في الواقع لا تهدف الى احلال السلام
لكن الى تشكيل تحالف معاد لروسيا
وفي الاخبار ايضا ناقش وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي مع رئيس هيئه الاركان المشتركه
الامريكيه التهديد الايراني على اسرائيل
والعالم وبحسب بيان اسرائيلي اكد وزير
الدفاع يعاف جالنت على اهميه التعاون
الدولي لمنع ايران من حيازه السلاح النووي
ذلك يتزامن مع وصول مدير العام للوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه رافائيل جروسسي الى
طهران لاجراء مناقشات بشان برنامج ايران
نووي بعد اكتشاف جزيئات من اليورانيوم
المخصب بمستوى قريب من صنع قنبله ذريه ومن
المقرر ان يلتقي خلال الزياره مدير منظمه
الطاقه الذريه الايرانيه محمد اسلامي
ومسؤولين ايرانيين اخرين بمن فيهم الرئيس
ابراهيم رئيس
وفي ايران ايضا ولكن في شان اخر خرج
محتجون بلوش عقب صلاه الجمعه في مظاهره
حاشده رافعين لافتات تحمل شعار الموت
للديكتاتور وللحرس الثوري
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر
زعم رئيس الايرانيه ابراهيم رئيسي ان من
وصفهم باعداء طهران هم من سعوا لاشاعه
التوتر والذعر بين الطلاب واولياء امورهم
على خلفيه قضيه تسمم الطالبات فقال الرئيس
الايراني انه وجه وزيري الداخليه والامن
بمتابعه قضايا تسمم في المدارس وتقديم
تقرير كامل عن الموضوع وكان التقرير اكد
التعرض مئات الطالبات للتسمم في جميع
انحاء البلاد في وقت حذرت فيه اليونيسف من
هذه الحادثه وتاثيرها على تعليم الفتيات
في ايران
خصبه لابتلاع اعذار النظام الايراني
وامتصاص اخطائه تحولت لها دول الغرب فهناك
يرمي انتهاكاته بمجالاتها المتعدده ليزعم
وقوف من يصفهم بالاعداء خلف كل ما يجري في
بلاده
فصول قمع الاحتجاجات لم تنتهي بعد ليتسرب
عبرها غاز تسبب بتسمم طالبات في المدارس
هذه ايضا تهمه الصقها بطريقه ما الرئيس
الايراني ابراهيم رئيسي بالغرب الذي يسعى
وفق تعبيره لاشاعه التوتر والذعر بين
الطلاب واولياء امورهم واثاره الاضطرابات
في ايران
معاناه الفتيات الايرانيات وسلبهن حق
التعليم بات موضع قلق دول غربيه عده بينها
الولايات المتحده والمانيا فهجمات السم
الخفيف فسرها السياسيون على انها استهداف
من قبل الجماعات المتشدده المعارضه لتعليم
الفتيات
يجب ان تتمكن الفتيات من الذهاب الى
المدرسه بلا خوف هذا حقهن الانساني ببساطه
يجب التحقيق بشكل كامل في كل الحالات
حالات تسمم متوسطه لمئات الفتيات اعلنت
عنها وزاره الصحه الايرانيه خلال الاشهر
القليله الماضيه وبين السوق الاتهامات
والقاء اللوم وجه رئيس وزير الداخليه
والامن بمتابعه قضايا التسمم في المدارس
فيما كلف رئيس مجلس الشورى محمد باقر
قليباث اربعه لجان برلمانيه بالتحقيق
واكتشاف اسباب الحوادث وقد تم القاء القبض
على ثلاثه اشخاص اشتبه بتورطهم في القضيه
لكن الاجهزه الامنيه نفت اكتشافها لماده
سامه قد تكون السبب في تسمم الطلبه
وفي العربيه ايضا
معارضه التركيه تخفق في الاتفاق على اسم
مرشحا رئاسيا لمواجهه اردوغان
لاننا نبحث دائما عن الفرص المثمره
والافكار المبدعه والملهمه ننطلق معا في
بيبان
[موسيقى]
بيبان فرص تصنع الرياده
نقطع بطن لننتقل الى تركيا وتطورات
الزلزال ايش اللي صارت وقت الزلزال اروي
لنا القصه سابدا بالسؤال
الصمت في هذا الموقع يحاول سماع اصوات
قادمه تحت الركاب
عدد الناجين عدد القتلى الجرحى المباني
المهدمه فلا يزال عشرات العائلات والاشخاص
تحت الانقاض لم تصل اليهم فرق الدفاع
المدني
هل هذه الارتدادات مستمره وممتى خطورتها
الرعب لا يزال مستمرا وجاءت هذه العاصفه
ايضا حديث عن زلزال قادم سيكون اكبر من
هذا الزلزال جديد ضرب نفس المنطقه
لم يحدث الزلزال في هذه المنطقه اشد من ما
حدث اليوم لان هناك بنايات مدمره ولكن لا
فرق اغاثه وصلت
هناك كلمه للرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغانو
لا يهتم بحياه
المدرسه هنالك المئات من سيارات الاسعاف
التي تنقل للاسف جثامين القتلى التي يتم
يعني اخراجها
من تحديد المساعدات الى شمال غرب سوريا هل
من ناجين ورغم مرور اثنتين وسبعين ساعه
على الزلزال المدمر اداره الكوارث التركيه
تحدث الارقام
اهلا بكم من جديد اعربه الخارجيه السعوديه
عن استنكار المملكه الشديد للتصريحات
المتطرفه التي ادلى بها احد مسؤولين
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من خلال مطالبته بمحو
قريه حوار الفلسطينيه واكدت الخارجيه
السعوديه رفض المملكه التام لهذه
التصريحات العنصريه مشدده على مطالبتها
للمجتمع الدولي بالاطلاع بمسؤولياته لردع
هذه الممارسات المشينه ووقف التصعيد
وتوفير الحمايه اللازمه للمدنيين
هذا وداع الاتحاد الاوروبي حكومه اسرائيل
الى التبرئ من تصريحات وزير الماليه
الاسرائيلي التي دعا فيها الى محو بلده
حواره الفلسطينيه الجنوبيه نابلس بعد
الاحداث الاخيره واكد الاتحاد الاوروبي ان
تصريحات الوزير الاسرائيلي غير مقبوله ولا
يمكن التسامح معها وجدد الاتحاد الاوروبي
تمسكه بمبادئ الشرعيه الدوليه لحل النزاع
الاسرائيلي الفلسطيني
هذا هو اجراء ممثل الاتحاد الاوروبي في
فلسطين زياره تفقديه الى بلده حواره في
نابلس في اعقاب تعرضها لسلسله من الهجمات
الدبلوماسي الاوروبي الذي وصل الى الضفه
الغربيه على راسي وفد كبير من سفراء
ودبلوماسيين اوروبيين شدد على تضامنه مع
الشعب الفلسطيني
هذا اكبر وفد دبلوماسي على الاطلاق على
مستوى رؤساء البعثات زار اي مكان في
فلسطين هذه علامه في حد ذاتها على التضامن
والوقوف معكم جنبا الى جنب
من جانبها كانت لندن حظت على اجراء تحقيق
في مقتل فتى فلسطيني قرب قلقيليه في الضفه
الغربيه يوم الخميس وعبرت القنصليه
البريطانيه في القدس على حسابها او في
حسابها على تويتر عن اسفها بسبب عدم
الاستقرار المستمر والخسائر في الارواح في
جميع انحاء الضفه الغربيه كما قررت دعوتها
الى ضبط النفس عند استخدام الجيش
الاسرائيلي للذخيره الحيه
في موضوع اخر اعلنت زعيم حزب الخير
المعارض التركي ميرال الاكشينار عن رفض
حزبها لترشيحه لزعيم المعارضه ورئيس حزب
الشعب الجمهوري كمالكيجار اوغلو في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه القادمه واوضحت
اكشينار ان خمسه زعماء من قاره احزاب
الطاوله السداسيه قرروا ترشيح كليتش رغم
كل المؤشرات التي تؤكد تقدم رئيس بلديه
اسطنبول اكرم امام اوغلو ورئيس بلديه
انقره من سوريا فاش في استطلاعات الراي
وامكانيه فوزهما بانتخابات الرئاسه مؤكده
ان حزبها لن يرضخ لضغوط الطاوله السداسيه
بترشيح
في المرحله الحاليه اضطر الحزب الصالح الى
الفرد واجبر على الاختيار بين الموت
والملاريا تماما كما حدث للامه التركيه
لسنوات وبالطبع لن يرضخ الحزب الصالح الى
هذا كحزب الواي اي اعربنا عن راينا في
ترشيحين اولئك الذين سمعناهم كثيرا في
الشوارع والمتاجر والساحات العامه لاكثر
من ثلاث سنوات تلك التي شهدناها في كل
مكان تقريبا اظهرتها امتنا بشده المحسوبيه
واولئك الذين رايناهم في جميع الاستطلاعات
العامه فازوا بفارق كبير على السيد
اردوغان لفتره طويله هذان الاسمان هما
عمده مدينه انقره السيد منصور يافاس وعمده
مدينه اسطنبول السيد اكرم امام اوغلو
وكانت احزاب المعارضه التركيه اعلنت امس
الاتفاق على اسم مرشح لخوض انتخابات
الرئاسه ضد الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان دون ان
يتم الكشف عن اسمه وتجتمع سته احزاب
معارضه رئيسيه على مدار اشهر للوصول الى
توافق حول اسم لمنافسه اردوغان الا ان هذه
الجهود تعاقدت مع تصريحات الاخيره
الى هنا من اسطنبول مراسل العربيه زيدان
اهلا بك زيدان زيدان هل الاعتراض من قبل
زعيمه حزب الخير هو على شخص كمال
ام على ترشيح
مرشح من حزب الشعب
نعم بدايه ابراهيم ومنتهى كل عام وانتم
بخير في قناه العربيه في عيد العربيه
العشرين مع دوام الامنيات بالتقدم
والرياده طبعا لا شك ان اعتراض ميرال
اكشنر هو على شخص كمالك الجدار اوغلو وليس
على حزب الشعب الجمهوري الى سيما ان كلا
الاسمين اللذان طرحتهما ميرال اكشنر هما
اكرم امام اوغلو رئيس بلديه اسطنبول
ومنصوريا واش رئيس بلديه انقره هما من حزب
الشعب الجمهوري وبالتالي كان الخلاف على
شخص كمالك الذي تقول ميرال اكشنر انه لا
يحظى بتاييد الطبقه المحافظه على وجه
التحديد وقواعد حزب الخير التي تتزاعمه
مراء الاكشنر وايضا الطبقه المحافظه من
بقيه الاحزاب لذلك كانت تعترض بشده لا
سيما ان لديها دراسات واستطلاعات راي تؤيد
ما تقول ما تقوله ميرال اكشنار بان فرص
كمال كالجدار اوغلو امام الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان اقل من فرص من فرص اكرم امام
اوغلو او منصوريه وبالتالي هي طرحت هذين
الاسمين يواش وامام اوجلو في اجتماعي يوم
امس على الطاوله الثلاثيه لكن الطاوله
السداسيه وزعماء الطاوله الثلاثيه خمسه من
هؤلاء طبعا توافقوا على كمالك الجدار
اوغلو
ميرال قالت فلنذهب الى استطلاعات راي او
دراسات في الشارع ومن ثم نقرر لكنهم رفضوا
وبالتالي هي طلبه ان تستشير حزبها وقياده
حزب الخير بالفعل تم هذا اليوم نعم هل
يمكن ان نقول انه حزب الخير اصبح وحده
يعني في هذه القضيه هناك
احزاب اخرى ما زالت موافقه على
سترشحه هل هذا خروج لحزب الخير من هذه
الطاوله السداسيه
نعم منتهى ما صرحت به ميرال اكشنر اليوم
هو يعتبر ورقه الطلاق السياسي من الطاوله
السداسيه لم تقل اننا خرجنا لكن كل
التصريحات والنقد اللاذع الذي وجهته
للطاوله السداسيه هذا يعني انها لا عوده
الى هذه الطاوله السداسيه يدلل على ذلك
الاتصالات التي جرت هذا اليوم بينما بقي
في الطاوله السداسيه او زعماء الاحزاب
الذين بقوا في الطاوله السداسيه ومن
المقرر ان يجتمع قاده هؤلاء الاحزاب
الخمسه يوم امس للتداول فيما في اخر
تطورات بعد خروج او بعد تصريحات ميرال
التي كانت لاذعه هذا اليوم بالتالي نستطيع
القول بشكل عملي وليس رسمي نعم نعم نعم
نعم طيب السؤال الاخير انه اذا بقي الوطن
على ما هو عليه زيدان
اذا بقي الوضع على ما هو عليه زيدان
اصوات حزب الخير لمن ستذهب
بحسب التحالف الذي ستتجه اليه ميرال اكشنر
نعم بدايه هي وضعت الكره في ملعب اكرم
امام اوغلو ومن سوريا واش وقالت لهما ان
نداء الشعب او دعتهما للاستجابه لنداء
الشعب وبالتالي في حال قرر احد هذين
الشخصين او هذين السياسيين الترشح لا شك
ان ميرال اكشنر ستتحالف معه وبالتالي
اصوات كتلتها او اصوات ناخبيه حزب الخير
سيذهب الى ستذهب الى احد هذين الرجلين في
حال لم يتم او لم يكن هناك اي استجابه
لدعوه مراء الاكشنر هذا بانتظار الخطوه
التاليه من ميرال اكشنر اما تحالف جديد او
الذهاب بشكل منفرد الى صناديق الاقتراع في
هذه الحاله ربما تشهد او تخسر بعض الاصوات
لصالح حزب الحركه القوميه الحزب الحزب
الذي اتت منه بالاصل ميرال اكشنر وهو الان
متحالف مع حزب مع حزب العداله والتنميه
بزعامه الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان وهذا طبعا
يصب في صالح رجب طيب اردوغان كل هذا
الانقسام انا اشكرك على وجودك معنا من
اسطنبول مراسل العربيه زيدان زنكلو
اعلنت القياده المركزيه الامريكيه عن
تنفيذها مع شركاء اخرين 48 عمليه ضد عناصر
تنظيم داعش في العراق وسوريا الشهر الماضي
واوضحت القياده ان هذه العمليات اسفرت عن
مقتل 22 عنصرا من التنظيم واعتقال 25
اخرين ووصفت العمليات ضد داعش بالمهمه
لمنع التنظيم من استعاده قدرته في المنطقه
ومهاجمه الحلفاء والمصالح الامريكيه في
الخارج
التمويل المالي كان اهم الركائز التي
اعتمد عليها تنظيم داعش للبقاء وتمويل
عملياته حيث لجا الى السيطره على المناطق
النفطيه واقام شبكه اموال سريه وحينما
انهار واصبح افراده في المخيمات وداخل
السجون لجا الى طريقه اخرى وللوصول الى
اول الخيوط توجهنا الى المخيمات التي
تحتجز فيها او تحتجز فيها عائلات التنظيم
شمال شرق سوريا داخل مخيم الروج مشهد غريب
حاولنا تفسيره وفهمه مكتب للصرافه وتحويل
الاملاح الاموال للداعشيات علنا يخضع
لرقابه قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه وفي الباطن
تخطيط يجري داخل خيانه داعشيات حملات لجمع
التبرعات وعمليات ابتزاز وتهريب تشرف
عليها خلايا التنظيم
امام نافذه مكتب الصرافه ينتظرنا بترقب
وصول حوالات ماليه مشهد سيبدو مالوفا لو
كان خارج اسوار هذا المكان لكن هن زوجات
مقاتل داعش وهذا مكتب صرافه داخل مخيم روج
الذي ياوي عائله التنظيم وجله من الاجانب
تسمح قوى الامن في المخيم التابعه لاداره
الذاتيه شمال سوريا لمكاتب الصرافه بالعمل
داخل مخيمات الدواعش تحت رقبتها
لصقيمين هنا والذين يقولون انها من
اقاربهم
لمساعدتهم على تكاليف الحياه من وين
الحواله
كم عاده ترسل لك ممكن
دولار نعم شهريا
[موسيقى]
يمكن لي كل عائله داخل المخيم تسلم ما بين
دولار امريكي شهريا رسميا يقول القائمون
على المخيمات ان الاموال ترسل من ادلب
التي تسيطر عليها فصائل مواليه لتركيا او
من داخل تركيا نفسها
مصادر الاموال كلياته من اهاليون على
اليوتيوب اهاليون موجودين بادلب اغلبيتهم
كلياتهم
ومن تركيا ويلي خارج
نطاق دوله تركيا او من ادلب كمان بعض
الاهالي منهم بيبعتوا على تركيا من تركيا
بيبعتوهم
من تركيا على ادلب ومن ادلب لماذا
تركيا كلياتهم هلا ما بعرف يعني هي اساس
المقر هي لتر
السماح بوصول الاموال لعائله التنظيم
يبرره المسؤولون هنا باسباب انسانيه
فمساعده المنظمات الاغاثيه غير كافيه لسد
احتياجات العائلات اليوميه لكن الخطير عدم
قدره احد على تحديد او تتبع مصادر التمويل
تضمن انها
اضمن النمو من داعش مثلا فيه 100 طريقه
داعش تقدر تحوليه من مناطق اللي انت
نصره وداعش وهاي كله وجميع عمله واحده
يعني ما في كبسه
تحت نساء وتنظيف في مخيمات شمال سوريا مره
كثيره على مدار السنوات الماضيه في جمع
الاموال عبر حملات تبرعات باسماء مشفره في
منصات ماليه كما يحصلن على مساعدات ماليه
من متعاطفين مع داعش والغطاء الابرز
عائلتهن
بعض التحقيق والدراسه عن هالوضع
الاغلبيه لانه في بعض التواصلات عن طريق
الهواتف
وبشكل علني انه نبعث هالمصاري للاخوات
الموجودين اللي يقاومون ضمن المخيم حتى
يقوم بتربيه اولادهم بشكل افضل
وعن طريق الهواتف بيجون توجيهات يعني هل
اموال كيف يتصرفوا فيها
اما الغايه فتمويل محاولات هروبهن او شراء
اسلحه او حتى شراء ولاءات النازحين
واللاجئين داخل المخيمات معلومات اوصلت
الاداره الذاتيه للتحالف الدولي ضد داعش
ودول غربيه تم اتخاذ بعض التدابير بالفتره
الماضيه فقط يتطلب عمل مستمر لانه يعني
بلكي بعض البنوك تم كشف عنهم امام يحاولون
يغيرون
بنوك اخرى او لمصادر اخرى
مصادر مداخل مخيم الهول رفضت الافصاح عن
هويتها كشفت ان خلايا داعش هددت عمال
اغاثه محليين يعملون مع منظمات دوليه اما
للحصول على اموال منهم او لاجبارهم على
مساعدتهم في تهريب اشخاص من داخل المخيم
فالتمويل والترهيب وفكر التنظيم المتشدد
ادوات يحافظ عليها استمرار بقائه وان كان
ذلك في المخيمات او السجون صار بن عيشوبه
العربيه من شمال شرق سوريا
دعت منظمه الصحه العالميه الصين الى مزيد
من الشفافيه لمعرفه اصل فيروس كورونا كما
قالت الصحه العالميه انها لم تتراجع عن
التحقيقات المرتبطه بمعرفه اصل الفيروس
عبر متظاهرون في جمهوريه الكونغو
الديمقراطيه عن رفضهم لزياره الرئيس
الفرنسي امامويل ماكرون لبلادهم وكانت هذه
التظاهرات جزء من سلسله احتجاجات بدات هذا
الاسبوع قبل وصول ماكرون الى المحطه
الاخيره من جوله في وسط افريقيا التي سعى
من خلالها الى الناي بنفسه عن الماضي
الاستعمار لفرنسا
تصاعدت الاحتجاجات والغضب الشعبي في
اليونان تمديدا بحادث التصادم الكارثي
الذي وقع بين قطارين قبل ثلاثه ايام وادى
الى مقتل 57 شخصا على الاقل متحدث باسم
الشرطه قال في ثاني كبرى مدن البلاد
لوكاله الانباء الفرنسيه ان المظاهره
تخللها القاء الزجاجات حارقه ورشق
بالحجاره لكن الهدوء عاد سريعا
كشف محققون المان لوكاله اسوشيات عن
العثور على اسلحه تشمل ثلاث قنابل يدويه
في منزل متطرف مشتبه به في قضايا متعلقه
بخطاب الكراهيه ضد الحكومه الالمانيه
والذي يعتقد انه من انصار حركه الرايخ
اليمنيه حيث ذكر ممثل الادعاء في ميونخ
انهم عثروا عند تفتيش شقه المشتبه به على
العديد من الاسلحه تشمل عده سكاكين ومسدس
نصف الي والاف الطلقات من الذخيره وثلاث
قنابل يدويه ويجري التحقيق معه للاجتباه
في تاييده لجرائم النازيه
قال للجيش الاندوني 14 شخصا على الاقل
قتلوا واصيب العشرات في حريق هائل في
مستودع وقود تديره الدوله قبل ان يسيطر
عليه رجال الاطفاء فقال الرئيس اركان
الجيش ان الحريق في المنشاه التي تديرها
شركه الطاقه الحكوميه في جاكارتا اسفر عن
اصابه 42 اخرين على الاقل
وهذا فاصل نتابع بعده هذه النشره بتغطيه
خاصه لعيد العربيه العشرين تفضلوا البقاء
معنا
وجود العربيه
كمحطه مميزه منتشره في كافه انحاء العالم
تقدم المعلومه من خلال قنوات الرئيسيه ومن
خلال الحدث ايضا اثر المسيره واعطى
المشاهد الفرصه لتكون لديه مصادر متنوعه
ومختلفه ومتعدده للمعلومه وهذا طبعا في
بعد نظر وفي رؤيا واستشراف للمستقبل من
حيث مهام واهداف
ورساله العربيه
وطوال عقدين من الزمن ظفرت العربيه
بلقاءات حصريه ومهمه مع زعماء وقاده من
دول المنطقه والعالم اجمع ما منحها السبق
في متابعه ملفات العالميه واقليميه وعربيه
عواصم غربيه وعربيه صعوبه انظارها الى
شاشه العربيه طوال هذه السنوات لمتابعه
اهم اللقاءات الحصريه على شاشتنا دعونا
نستذكر بعضا منها معكم العربيه هي منبر
عربي مهم جدا
وقناه يتابعونها السعوديين والعرب بشكل
مكثف
ونعتقد انها رسالتنا سوف تصل للسعوديين
والعالم العربي من خلال هذا المنظر
الى ما قدرت بيروت وين رايح يا ابو عمار
قلت لهم انا فلسطين
واتكلمنا في الموضوع وطلعت على بغداد
السفير الايام اي منطقتكم او اوروبا هم
حاصروا كل القنوات التجاريه الشاب قال
كلمته عند تم سحب الثقه من هذه الحكومه
وخرج في ميدان الشهداء التي تعاملت بها
حتى نجحت بكل هذه السنوات
لا انفسنا
للمتابعه انضم الينا من الرياض مشاري
الدايدي الكاتب الصحفي ومقدم برنامج
الندوه على قناه العربيه اهلا بك ومن
القدس معنا مراسل العربيه زياد حلبي اهلا
بك وكل عام وانتم بخير وايضا من نيويورك
مراسل العربيه طلال الحاج كل عام وانتم
بخير
كل عام وانتم بخير جميعا وبدي ابدا مع
زميلنا زياد حلبي من القدس استعرضنا معا
بعض اللقاءات مع زعماء العالم هذه ليست
كلها بالتاكيد لكن زياد انت كنت من اخر
الناس الذين التقوا بالزعيم الراحل ابو
عمار
حدثنا عن تلك المقابله
اولا كل عام وانتم بالف خير بطبيعه الحال
بدون اد نشك بانها كانت مقابله خاصه
للعربيه وفي توقيت ايضا كان لافتا جدا
اعتقد جازما بانها كانت المقابله الاخيره
على هواء مباشره للرئيس الفلسطيني الراحل
ياسر عرفات في تلك المرحله كانت مقابله
عمليا
طلبتها العربيه في اللحظه الاخيره
وافق عليها الرئيس ياسر عرفات وصلنا على
عجل وبدانا البث المباشر خلال دقائق وكان
محتدا جدا عمليا في تلك
المقابله بعدها باشهر عمليا اتضح بانه بات
مريضا وبعدها بوقت قصير رحل عمليا يصل
عرفات اعطى اكثر من مقابله حقيقه لقناه
العربيه في خلال السنوات
الماضيه كان لديه دائما هذه القابليه
للتعاون في في هذا
الموضوع بدون الكثير من
المقدمات كان على طريقته الخاصه ايضا في
هذه المقابله
للحديث واذكر عندها في تلك المقابله
بالذات بانه قال لي برات عديده اعطاني
تقريرا على الهواء مباشره يثبت بان
اسرائيل استخدمت اليورانيوم
المقدم في تلك الفتره
وبالتالي كانت بالفعل واحده من المقابلات
اللافته للعربيه في تلك الفتره صحيح
طلال الحاج اهلا بك وكل عام وانت بخير
وانت وجميع الزملاء
ربما تحطمت الارقام القياسيه في اجراء
مقابلات مع الامناء العامين اذا ما
اعتبرناهم يعني
بدرجه رئيس
حدثنا عن كواليس لقاءات لقاءات الامناء
العامين ولماذا كانوا يخصوا قناه العربيه
بهذه اللقاءات التي يعني عاده ما تكون اول
قناه وايضا اكبر عدد من اللقاءات معها
لماذا
اولا كل عام وانتم ومتابعينا بالف خير بدر
ومنتهى بالفعل هذا حدث والمصداقيه اعتقد
في رايه هي العامل الاهم في المعادله
مصداقيه القناه وسمعتها ومدى انتشارها
وكذلك مصداقيه المراسل وعلاقته الشخصيه مع
كبار المسؤولين وصناع القرار هي صحافه
فعلا ولكن في نفس الوقت حسن اداره
للعلاقات العامه
بالنسبه للامناء العامين نحن
فعلا لدينا الرقم القياسي في عدد
المقابلات مع الامين العام كوفي عنان وكان
رحمه الله رجلا
ده حكمه وده هيبه وكانت اخر مقابله له في
ذلك الوقت عندما ترك في عام
2000 كانت معنا مع العربيه في يومه الاخير
وغادرت معه مكتبه سويا في واقع الامر
بالنسبه
بالرقم القياسي لدينا سبع مقابلات معه
مقارنه باي صحفي اخر او اي شبكه اعلاميه
اخرى سواء مكتوبه او مرئيه بالنسبه لكوفي
عن لدينا ايضا رقم القياسي في اجراء
المقابلات معه
ثلاثه عشر مقابله واقرب منافس
تقصد بانكيمون اما بالنسبه للامين العام
الحالي
بنكي نعم نعم ماذا قلت قلت فعلا
سبعه معكم في عنان 13 ما بانكيمون وربما
مع غوتيرش اول مقابله اعطاها بعد تعيينه
كانت مع مع قناه العربيه
نعم بعد ان عينه
الجمعيه العامه صعد الينا هنا في هذا
الاستوديو وجلس الينا في اول لقاء
تلفزيوني له او لقاء صحفي وخرجنا على شاشه
قناه العربيه الحدث في ذلك اليوم بالفعل
بدي اروح لمشاري الزايدي الكاتب الصحفي
ومقدم برنامج الندوه على قناه العربيه
ومشاري فقط يعني حتى نوضح الامر للجمهور
احنا كلنا دائما بنسعى للقاءات مع القاده
لانه
بنحاول نكون سباقين فيما يمكن ان نحصل
عليه من هؤلاء القاده القاده حول رؤيتهم
للتغيير سواء في بلادهم او في الاماكن
الصراع والنزاع او في العالم انت مشاري
بقلمك
وبوجودك على شاشه العربيه الحقيقه وشاهدتك
مجروحه واحد من رموز التنوير في العالم
العربي حدثني عن تجربتك كلها في قناه
العربيه حتى الان كانت عندك ست سباكشن من
برنامج الندوه
او قبل ان احدثك اول شيء ابارك لكم
هذا عيد الميلاد العشرين لبيتنا العربيه
واتذكر بهذه المناسبه ما قاله نزار قباني
في عيد ميلادك العشرين يا قمري فكرت فكرت
فيما سوف اهديه كل الهدايا او كل كل
الخيارات تبدو لي محدده يا من لعينيك كل
العمر يعطيه طبعا يتحدث عن حاله عشق كما
نعرف في نزاريات قباني لكن لنا ان نحورها
ونجعلها حاله هيام بالصحافه نعتقد ان
العربيه
اختطت مسارا خاصا في هذا في في المشهد
الاعلامي العربي واشكر لك استاذه منتهى
ولا اريد ان ارد يعني المديح بمديح لكن
فعلا انا اعتقد ان خبرتك التي تكونت عبر
هذه المده هي ايضا جزء من مزايا العربيه
وايضا الزملاء الم العربيه اصبحت ليست
مجرد منصه لتقديم الاخبار او البرامج بل
هي منبر لبث التنوير ولبث قيم المهنه انا
اعتقد اننا اليوم نعيش خطر كبير في انحشار
قيم مهنه الصحافه التي
حضرتك امتداد طبيعي لها والتي نحاول اليوم
ان يكون لها وجود القيم المهنيه التي
تتعرض لخطر كبير بسبب اجتياح السوشيال
ميديا
ونشوء فقاقيع لا نعلم من اين اتتنا ولا
الى اين تذهب لا يقيمون وزنا لمصداقيه
الخبر لا يقومون وزنا للموضوعيه اليوم
شاهدت على شاشه العربيه الجميل الاستاذ
جاسر الجاسر وهو من ابرز الصحفيين
السعوديين ترى تحرير عده صحف يقول
الموضوعيه لا تعني عدم عدم التلون او
الانحياز المطلق في الصحافه اعتقد انه مثل
الخل والعنقاء يعني اشياء نتحدث بها وليست
موجوده لكن الموضوعيه هي المطلوبه الحزام
ايضا بالقيم المهنيه وانا في ظن وشاهدت
مجروحه ان هذا ما تمثله مؤسسه كمؤسسه
العربيه
وصحفيين لامعين امثالك وامثال الاستاذ
ابراهيم في هذه المنصه شكرا انا بدي اتوجه
بسؤال الك منتهى يعني حتى هذا السؤال يعني
مشروع لك انت اجريت الكثير من المقابلات
ايضا مع زعماء السؤال انه لماذا يعني
يختار هؤلاء العربيه منبر لايصال رسالتهم
للشعوب العربيه شوف ابراهيم صحيح انا
اجريت العديد من اللقاءات مع كثير من
زعماء العالم العربي وزعماء العالم اخرهم
كان رئيس اندونيسيا ودوده الحقيقه
الاختيار قناه العربيه لانها يعني هو يعلم
تماما
الجمهور الذي تتوجه له قناه العربيه هو
يعلم الموضوعيه والمهنيه اللي بنتعامل
فيها بقناه العربيه هو يريد ان يصل رايه
الى قطاع كبير من الراي العام العربي اللي
هو بتمثله قناه العربيه الان احنا مثل ما
قال الاستاذ مشاري قبل قليل بالاخر لسنا
ما يطلبه الجمهور يعني احنا
لا نفكر بما يريد ان يستمع الي الناس
ونعود ونكرر ونقوله نحن نحاول ان نبني على
اسس
منذ بدء العربيه قبل عشرين عاما اتفقنا
عليها المرحله القادمه في عمر العربيه كل
لقاءات وكل الحوارات وكل نشرات الاخبار
وكل البرامج تصب في هذا في هذا الاساس
هناك في ذلك الوقت فهم عميق لهذا التوجه
او بعد نظر كما كان لدى العربيه وربما
اعود بالسؤال لك مشاري انه العربيه ربما
اختارت في نشاتها ان لا تكون منبر ايضا
لزعماء التنظيمات المتطرفه بينما تصدى
اخرون لهذا الامر برايك تاثير هذا الامر
على ارث العربيه كيف كان
تاثير ايجابي بلا شك ونعتقد ان العربيه
كسبت الرهان حين قاومت اغراء ان تكون
منصه لعرض خطابات اسامه بن لادن وايمن
الظواهري او او
البغدادي او غيرهم طبعا عدم العرض لا يعني
عدم تناول الماده كخبر يعني انا بمقدوري
ان اتناول خطبه اسامه بن لادن واخذ منها
استل منها الماده الخبريه لكن لا ان امنحه
الهواء والوقت لينظر ويضع السياقات التي
يريدها
ويمارس هنقول التنويم المغناطيسي او السحر
على الاخرين لا هذه ليست وظيفه
بالعربيه انه ليش ما بنبث هاي اللقاءات
ليش ما بنتحدث عنه ليش منستضيف ما بنستضيف
يعني هذه الفئه من
المتحدثين كنا ننتقد على ذلك لكن اصرينا
على موقفنا
وتبين ان هذا الاصرار كان هو الخيار
الصحيح لانه الان يعني انت اذا تريد ماذا
قال بالله مثلا بن لادن اعترف لنفترض
المهم لنفترض هذا واقع اعترف في احدى
التسجيلات مع الشخص الكسيح الذي كان يجلس
معه وكان هذا اول اعتراف في بث بانهم هم
من كان خلف تفجيرات 11 سبتمبر جميل هذا
خبر ليس بمقدوري ان اهمله اضعه في سياقه
واضع كلام بن لادن بصوت بصوت والصوره الذي
يقر فيه بان تنظيم ما هو شخصيا من كان
وراء هجمات 11 سبتمبر لكن لا اضع المجال
او الهواء له لكي يذكر مبرراته انا اعتقد
هذه ليست وظيفه الاعلام المحترم يعني
صحيفه الاعلام وحتى على فكره حتى في كلمات
الرؤساء والزعماء والشاشه هذه لها سياق
يعني تاخذ منها الماده الخبريه الا اذا
كان هناك قناه مرادفه مثلا لمن يريد
التوسع هذا موضوع اخر
[موسيقى]
هذا صحيح بدون ان شك يعني التغطيه في
منطقه صراع الدائم كهذه المنطقه منذ مئه
عام عمليا هذا
يتطلب طبعا مع تراكم الخبره
للقناه في التغطيه طبعا هذا كان يتطلب منذ
البدايه ليس فقط مواكبه الحدث من حيث
الحدث وانما ايضا ان تتميز في المعلومه
اعتقد بان ربما هذا هو ما احدث النقل
النوعيه في في الكثير من الاحيان بان تكون
القناه مصدرا للخبر يعني في السيره
الذاتيه احيانا للصحافيين يمكن ان يغطي
حربا في بشكل او باخر لكن مثلا في هذه
المنطقه خمسه حروف في السنوات الاخيره
حروب لم تكن لاول مره تبث على الهواء
مباشره مثل حرب تموز هي كانت الحرب الاولى
التي بثت على الهواء مباشره عمليا وزياد
كان عندك طريقه في تمرير الاخبار
بطريقه غير مباشره
هذا هذا صحيح يعني انا اعترف بانني من
اكثر ربما الصحفيين الذين يتجاوزون
الرقابه العسكريه في اسرائيل في التغطيه
في الحروب
وبطبيعه الحال في بعض الاحيان تكون هناك
تقييدات كثيره في العربيه اعطيك مثالا ان
كان في الحروب على قطاع غزه او في حرب
لبنان كان الاتفاق مثلا مع التحرير ومع
المذيعين في الاستوديو مثلا ان نقول على
الهواء مباشره لو ان خمسه جنود قتلوا قبل
قليل لما استطعت ان اقول ذلك بفعل الرقابه
العسكريه طبعا بشكل افتراضي عاده كانوا
يكتب على الشاشه مقتل خمسه جنود
اسرائيليين كان واضحا بانني احاول ان اقول
بان هناك خمسه قتله في الجيش الاسرائيلي
في هذه اللحظه وكل وسائل الاعلام حتى في
اسرائيل كانت تنقل هذا الموضوع تكسر
الرقابه وبعدها يضطرون للاعتراف بعد ساعه
او ساعتين هذه عشرات المرات كانت تتكرر في
التغطيات الاكيد هو ان ربما المعلومه لم
يكن ربما في العالم العربي
يعني
موضوع المعلومه واضح في النشرات الاخبار
وفي قوه المعلومات ودقه المعلومات كما حدث
مع العربيه في السنوات منذ تاسيسها وحتى
اليوم بطبيعه الحال ايضا علينا ان نشير
ربما ليس من يراهم المشاهد على الشاشه فقط
يعملون في هذا الموضوع هناك الكثير من
الجنود خلف هذه الشاشه على الارض من
يحدثون الفرق باعتقادي في التغطيات خاصه
في تغطيات الحروب هذا جهد جماعي يعني
احيانا يكون غير مسبوق طلال اعود اليك من
جديد كم مره حسيت وانت بتجري لقاءاتك مع
الامناء العامين او حتى مع
المندوبين للدول الموجودين في الامم
المتحده وهي كثيره وكثيره جدا كم مره حسيت
انها حققت لك ما تريد حققت لك السبق
الصحفي انك اخذت شيء للعربيه لم يكن موجود
على اي مكان اخر في على المستوى الصحفي
ليس دائما منتهى اذكر مقابلات مع كوفي
عناء مثلا كنت اخرج من المقابله باخبار
وخاصه مقابل التي
استفردنا بها حول الوضع في سوريا اما
بالنسبه لبنك فكانت دائما قلق كان رجلا
طيبا ولكن خبريا كانت المقابلات 13
فقيره في الاخبار وهذا في المعلومه ضميري
يمليه يمليه يملي علي ان اقول ذلك
نعم فقيرا في المعلومه
اشياء كثيره ربما احرج
القاده او الشخصيات التي اكرمتني بالجلوس
الي
لا اريد ان احرج احد ولكن اود ان اذكر
مقابلات حصريه انفردنا بها وكانت فعلا
مهمه جدا مثل تلك مع وزير الدفاع الامريكي
عام 2006 حيث اختار العربيه لمنح اللقاء
الوحيد في ذلك الوقت بالرغم انني كنت هنا
اجير مكتب نيويورك ولكن تم استدعائي الى
واشنطن واجرينا المقابله وبثتها
اخذتها منا جميع القنوات الامريكيه اي بي
سي ام بي سي كلها لان نتصادفت مع منادات
كبار الجنرالات في القوات الامريكيه
المختلفه بين يقدم راس في الاستقالته خاصه
لسوء الوضع العسكري الامريكي في العراق
حينئذ وقوع خسائر كبيره لهم وكذلك فضائح
ابو غريب سجن ابو غريب واعت من خلال
المقابله للشعب العراقي
بما اما حدث في ابو غريب وكانت مهمه جدا
اما مؤخرا اذكر لقائنا الحصري ولاكثر من
ساعه في 28 من ابريل معاميد الدبلوماسيه
الروسيه وزير الخارجيه
اثناء الحرب الاوكرانيه وفي بدايتها كان
لقاء مفصلا لاكثر من ساعه تبين لي من خلال
ان روسيا لا تريد وقف الحرب ومصممه على
المضي في ضم اكبر
بكل هذا المجال معلش اخذنا الوقت ولكن نحن
بنعرف انه القائد عندما يوافق على
المقابله يريد ان يقول ما يريد ان يقوله
هو وليس ما نريد نحن ان نستخرج منه طلال
الحاج شكرا جزيلا لك مشاري زايده شكرا
جزيلا لك زياد حلبي شكرا جزيلا لك ايضا
وكل عام وانتم بالف خير
وانتهت هذه الساعه اخبريه جديده بعد قليل
تفضلوا البقاء معنا ابقوا معنا الى اللقاء
يعطيك العافيه
[موسيقى]
اعتبر العربيه يعني صراحه من اعلامي يعني
ما علم حتى في مجال يعني لها بصمه
لاضافه في مجال
المعلومه في مجال التحليل يعني اضافت يعني
قفزه نوعيه
[موسيقى]
نشا على عشب كره القدم منذ صغره تنقل بين
اهم النوادي حول العالم
حطم الارقام القياسيه بحصوله على اكثر من
61 جائزه فرديه من بينها خمس كرات ذهبيه
كريستيانو رونالدو
اما
هو الاثر التاريخي الذي سيتركه النجم
البرتغالي للاجيال من بعده كريستيانو
رونالدو الوحيد والاوحد السد التاسع على
شاشه عربيه
تويتر فيسبوك انستغرام تيك توك يوتيوب
[موسيقى]
عالم مليء بالمعلومات
والافكار الجديده والحوارات
في كيف بنشوف العالم حولنا
وكيف بنشوف بعضنا وكيف بنشوف انفسنا
في هذا الكون الافتراضي الفسيح
نحلل الارقام ونبسطها لكي تعرف اكثر
تعاملنا مع الاحداث باحترافيه بدقه
وبمصداقيه الاسواق العربيه حولت الاطلاع
على اخبار المال والاعمال الى ثقافه عامه
لم يعد سرفا بل ضروره ان يبدو نهارك وانت
ملم بكل ما يحرك الاسواق عربيا
العربيه 20 عاما واكثر
[موسيقى]